[Music]
kim kardashian sharing intimate moments
with pete davidson might be exciting
enough but leave it to little sis chloe
to spice things up a little more well at
least for those of us in the comments
section you just gotta roll with it so
what happened well it begins with a
sneak peek at season two of the
kardashians and kim teasing her new
romance life is good i have a new
boyfriend i'm just having a really good
time soon after this teaser dropped the
beauty mogul instagramed some pda filled
picks
[Music]
yeah pete and kim are looking head over
heels for each other and as chloe points
out emphasis on the heels
and the toes i can't genuinely i cannot
believe it she puts it to kim in the
comments writing do you guys have a foot
fetish too
but kim speaks up before things get out
of hand she simply replies nope perhaps
chloe has just come to expect the
unexpected from this couple and we can't
really blame her because this kim and
pete moment from the new trailer left us
at a loss for words
yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
so it's looking like we'll be seeing
more pete in season two along with more
behind the scenes looks at the famous
family kim we're gonna see so much from
you a new love story for you
and i think the fans really love seeing
you as you said so at peace it was so
nice to see you doing your own thing and
owning so many moments
but now you're at peace with this guy
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him
um
he's just super genuine
the episodes are more documentary style
and i think that you have a real insight
into what the girls are doing not only
you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes i
wanted to believe that tristan could
change i wanted to trust him and it
seems chloe isn't letting last season's
drama with her ex tristan thompson and
his paternity scandal ruin her shot at
finding the one i do believe in love
when you love you know you're alive you
have these feelings
of course more kravis is also on the way
we'll see them plan for their wedding we
are starting to talk wedding dresses
what is in the media is sort of things
that we feel we need to film because
it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long no matter how crazy things are
[Music]
we're always going to be family
[Music]
you